here's an idea of just how wide an area
this storm covers some of the heaviest
rain 15 inches since this storm began
has fallen in Jacksonville more than a
hundred miles east of hermas Center the
st. John River which runs through the
city is overflowing now
Jericka Duncan is along the coast in
Atlantic Beach just outside Jacksonville
she spoke to the city's mayor Jericka
good morning good morning I did just get
off the phone with the city's mayor and
he told me that these winds are gusting
at at least 80 miles per hour again
we're on Atlantic Beach which is the
barrier island all of the bridges in and
out of to the city has been shut down
and have been shut down since about 8:45
last night we also know that this city
has experienced storm surge we've been
talking about it throughout the coverage
of this storm but just take a look right
here you can see it better as the Sun is
starting to come up a little bit but the
storm surge is historic for the
Jacksonville area as a whole so aside
from the wind you have flooding we're
told by the mayor that a lot of the
roads here and Atlantic Beach are
impassable they're concerned about
people coming out because right now this
is definitely no time to be out in this
this is the worst that we have seen it
you take a look at just how the wind is
moving these palm trees again we're here
along the coast of we're seeing and
feeling the worst of it along with the
sand just helping us here in the face
but the main issue and concern is that
people do not venture out at this point
we did hear of at least one accident due
to flooding but this is only the
beginning again we're hundreds of miles
away and yet we're still feeling the
effects here of Armagh here on the east
Jericka thank you very much